voici dominique perrault napoléon et
ousmane tonton apéro à la dire
or dominique perrault je te demande pas
où aller en vacances parce que t'as pas
dû prendre beaucoup de vacances comme la
décision de te confier la grande
bibliothèque à la très grande
bibliothèque la bibliothèque de france a
été prise au mois d'août ça pas du show
mais c'était en fait je suis revenu de
vacances avec ses 8
[Applaudissements]
mais
mitterrand mitterrand je les ai vus
après la décision de justice ont été
annoncées par le les gens de la
bibliothèque de france et j'ai vu
mitterrand lendemain il m'a demandé si
j'étais content ouais et il ya des quoi
je dis oui certainement je suis très
content et que surtout que c'était assez
formidable pour le jeune architecte
français de gagner enfin un concurrent
d'ericsson à penser qu'il faut aborder
l'once à l'événement comme l'événement
ça fait quoi avant la tgb j'ai fait une
école à marne la vallée pour les
ingénieurs par chambre de commerce de
paris qui forme des ingénieurs de tri
cambier qui est un peu la vie et
d'ordinateurs c'est ce que tous les
ingénieurs et elle c'est une aile et
enel qui plane et qui est venu se poser
la rondelle blanche 300 mètres de long
un hectare de plastique pour faire une
toiture et tu penses que tu as été
choisi pour quoi finalement
je pense que j'ai pas vu malheureusement
encore tous les projets
les maquettes sont très grands et le
parti elles sont encore dans des caisses
dans certaines elles sont retournées
dans des caisses alors c'est un petit
peu difficile pour moi d'arriver à bien
comprendre mais d'après ce que les
bruits
gérer les rapports divers et variés sur
les projets je pense que si les dires du
vide qui est de la place au lieu de
faire un bâtiment de 200 mille mètres
carrés toi tu as fait un trou quoi tu as
fait une place oui j'ai fait un lieu pas
vraiment ouais un endroit où on va ouais
c'est une idée je crois que ça répond un
peu à l'idée
il y avait deux termes dans le programme
mis un temple oui un supermarché donc un
endroit un trésor disponible donc un
endroit où tout le monde peut aller où
peut-on aller le plus facilement sinon
sur place
ouais il le vide à paris entre commencé
alors tu as fait une place qui sera un
peu la concorde de l'est c'est ce qu'on
dit avec un belvédère de 400 mètres sur
la scène et comme tu dis c'est pas un
front de seine c'est un fond de scène
quoi c'est un fou ça pour dire que c'est
ce qui est en avant de la scène
c'est à nous c'est une terrasse ouais
effectivement 400 m 3 8 mètres au dessus
du quai et qui embrasse complètement
tout le parc de bercy qui va être
construit de côté tous un site
absolument superbe
est-ce qui est aussi superbe ces cas une
colline mais rien
détour et dont il ya toute une
population donc été un petit peu
considérée comme vivant dans des
endroits dégueulasse etc qui par
l'installation de cette bibliothèque va
retrouver un petit peu limité et tout un
quartier qu'à retrouver une dignité qui
va retrouver la scène est ce qu'il ya
une rixe appelle la rue de rivoli de
l'est elie un jardin intérieur qui est
de la taille du palais royal et les
fenêtres des salles de lecture donne sur
des armes à l'art et au fond c'est à
dire c'est un espace qui est dedans
dehors c'est dans la ville mais en même
temps ce en dehors de la ville car s'est
incrusté au milieu de la fin donc les
gens booking en contrebas sous les
arbres sans être gênés par la réactivité
la ville et aux quatre coins il ya
quatre livres ouverts quatre grandes
tours translucide dans lesquelles les
livres sont rangés
ça c'est un système de balises c'est à
dire tous les monuments à paris en 6e
sur ce repère c'est pas une silhouette
qui ne devrait donc le site est le signe
ce repère par les 4 iv des phares et
balises
la décision a été prise un an après que
le président n'ait parlé pour la
première fois on a dit que c'était un
peu prématuré et que ça avait été décidé
très vite parce que mitterrand ou les
l'inaugurer durance enfin avant la fin
de son deuxième septennat pas d'accord
avec ça non je pense que il ya deux
vitesses
et à faire un bâtiment est viré occuper
ce bâtiment quand on quand on se balade
à bio tech nationale il va falloir du
temps pour que tous les livres soient
triés classés répertoriés
encensé et cetera proposé assuré tout
cela donc ça ça apprendre ça va aller à
la vitesse
une bibliothèque mais nous on fait un
bâtiment est capable de recevoir une
bibliothèque et de démarrer un quartier
de saint alban de le faire la sandale
tendu comme il faut ça va tomber mais
non on va le faire
on va faire on va bien le fait très
large de la défense l'opéra de la
bastille la pyramide du louvre la
bibliothèque de france est ce que tu
crois qu'on peut parler d'un style
mitterrand en architecture lorsqu'on
veut parler c'est d'une action
très forte de françois mitterrand sur la
ville sur le pour la france possède et
d'actes tous ces bâtiments ces bâtiments
par la capitale mais ces bâtiments qui
renvoie un pays à une nation et c'est
vrai que depuis napoléon iii on n'avait
pas vous n'avez pas beaucoup vu
s'affronter les durées qu'est ce que
j'ai à dire les banques sur la durée ça
t'en penses quoi de ces trois monuments
là ne dis pas qu'ils sont tous très bien
parce que franchement non ils sont au
large c'est bien c'est très bien c'est
très bien fait
la pyramide est très bien on peut dire
c'est bien aussi sans aucun aucune
arrière pensée et en perdant l'opéra
c'est un peu moins bien que lui aussi
paré koussa pas terrible non mais c'est
un peu moins bien message passe est
vraiment lié à
aux histoires des concours dans les
concours il faut qu'ils aient une
rencontre y'a pas une évidence marche
pas ce rendez vous de même pas dû
détruire la gare de la baisse
rendez vous manqué un rendez vous manqué
mais nous c'est une tu ferais quoi à
paris si tu avais le pouvoir
si tu étais haussmann ou napoléon iii où
françois mitterrand
c'est vrai quoi imagine comme ça on te
donne paris du faites ce que vous voulez
faire du vrai moi je ferai des grands
projets techniques
ouais aujourd'hui à genre
revoir la question du gaz les bagnoles
et quand je dis grand projet technique
parce que je veux faire l'ingénieur mais
je doublerai ça d'un projet
j'aurais architecturale d'un projet
généreux et a par exemple il ya un truc
comme le boulevard sébastopol piétonnier
voilà qui est on y est mais c'est
fondamental c'est assez évident c'est
évident savidan gare du nord gare de
l'est
les tgv et du nord de l'europe va
arriver en bas le rer avec toute la
banlieue toute la france qui arrive en
bas du cétacé peu beaubourg le louvre et
cetera c'est malheureux faut arrêté de
circuler il faut marcher et à part ça
qui me ferait quoi bon ça c'est une idée
comme ça moi j'ai une réelle idée venue
du vous fait quoi
je détruirai qu après c'est ce que tu
conspiraient tu détruirait quoi un truc
est vraiment insupportable tu te dis pas
la tour montparnasse tout la phrase et
où je suis pas sûr que je détruire et
moi je même la tour montparnasse
il faut moi je ferai un travail aux
paysages à dire que j'arrêterais de
faire d'un côté l'urbanisme de côté
leurs factures sur les espèces de
d'immenses tableaux sur paris qui
définirait les nouveaux paysages lire
les cartes postales que dans 20 ans on
vendra sur paris et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux